[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So Josh, thank
you so much for being here.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
Yes, my pleasure.
SPEAKER: I'm so
excited to have you.
So to get things started,
I thought I'd just
do a few rapid fire questions.
So for these ones, just
answer the first thing
that comes to your mind.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: OK.
SPEAKER: OK, first one.
Favorite song in "Hamilton."
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
"Yorktown," for sure.
SPEAKER: Last thing you Googled.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I
want to say it was--
I can just check.
Let's find out.
It was something super random.
It might have been a Jimmy
Johns location there somewhere.
SPEAKER: That's good.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
Yeah, there you go.
SPEAKER: Favorite city
you have performed in, not
including Denver.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: OK.
Because Denver's first.
SPEAKER: Yes.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
Honestly, I loved--
they've all been so good.
Audiences are like subtly
different in each one.
I really liked San
Diego as a city.
I really vibed with that city.
It was super cool.
Yeah, I really liked it there.
That was fun.
No, no, no.
I changed my mind.
Tempe was the best.
Because it was on
a college campus.
So the energy there
was just so awesome.
And there was a
professor that used
to teach at Ithaca
College, which
is the school that I went to.
And then he now teaches at ASU.
So I got to do a
talk at his class.
And all his students
randomly saw me go on.
Because I was on for about a
week for Jefferson, Lafayette
and Jefferson.
So it was just like--
I don't know.
It was super cool.
I felt just a tiny bit famous.
SPEAKER: Two more
rapid fire ones--
one word to describe "Hamilton."
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
There's a bunch.
SPEAKER: You can do a few.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I know.
I'll say-- what's a
groundbreaking for sure one?
Movement.
It's such a movement.
You know, it's more than--
I mean, it's obviously
musical theater.
But I feel like it's done
so much more than that.
And the timing of
it, and cultural
implication that it has--
it's just, yeah, I
would say movement.
SPEAKER: Cool.
Last rapid fire--
coolest person you've met
while performing in the show.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
I want to say--
I have a story about it.
Have you guys seen the
show "Crazy Ex-Girlfriend?"
Yeah, I love that show.
And Rachel Bloom is
the main person in it.
I went on as Lafayette-Jefferson
once, and then it was in LA.
And after the show I saw her,
and I was like, oh, my gosh.
And I was just
creeping from afar.
I was saying,
that's Rachel Bloom!
Like, what do I do?
Do I just say hi?
No, I can't do that.
That's stupid.
And then she saw me, and
she was like, oh, my gosh!
It's Thomas Jefferson.
And I said, no way!
It was the craziest thing.
Yeah.
And she just came up to me,
and we chatted for a second,
and that was really cool.
And Seth Green, too--
he was really nice.
Yeah.
I mean, we've met
a bunch of people.
That's probably my most
notable interaction,
just because that was so
crazy that she called me out.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Awesome.
Cool.
OK.
So now we'll get to
some bigger questions.
Can you start off by telling
us a little bit about all
of the characters
you play in the show,
and what it's like to be in
the room where it happens?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yo.
OK.
So it's funny.
So Offstage Principle
Standby is my title,
which basically means I'm hired
for the sole purpose of just
being there in case
something happens,
so I can go in whenever.
Or before the show, I'll
get notice maybe two,
three hours before.
Somebody asked me, how
early do you usually know?
Is it a couple of days?
Do they tell you
like the week before?
And I'm like, literally
anywhere from like months
to like a couple of minutes.
Last week, I was playing
Uno with the other swings,
and the stage manager came in.
She's like, hey, you're going to
be Jefferson in the second act.
And that was just it.
That's what happens.
SPEAKER: So mid-show.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
Mid-show.
And that's only happened
to me like a handful
of times where that happens.
So honestly, originally,
that was really--
I've never had to do
anything like that before.
That was really hard.
And it was really stressful.
And especially with this brand.
I mean, it's so
larger than life.
It's just huge.
And it's so-- I'm so
thankful to be a part of it,
but at the same time, there's
a gravity to it-- or there was.
I mean, I don't so
much feel this anymore.
I have relatively
gotten used to it.
But at the beginning,
it was very
crazy to have to just
be, yes, I'm enough.
I can do it.
You know?
It's a lot.
But I don't know.
Now I really love it.
You just never know what your
day is going to turn into.
I don't know.
It's so much fun for me.
Especially because,
I don't know,
I like to consider
myself somebody
who goes with the flow.
So it's just kind of like--
I don't know.
It's such a weird
thing to be able to do.
I'm very proud of it now.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like I went in
a different direction.
SPEAKER: No.
That's totally fine.
Do you have a favorite role
you get to play in the show?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Honestly,
I think I relate most with
Laurens-Philip.
But the funnest role for
me is for sure Jefferson.
I mean, you just,
you literally--
you just get to be extra.
It's so much fun.
[LAUGHTER]
It's the most.
It's the best.
Literally, you come out--
I don't know if you
guys have seen it,
but at the very
beginning of the act,
you come out on a staircase, and
you're just in a velvet suit.
And you'll hear a couple
of people from the back
go like, woo!
And then, I don't know.
This is what I do.
I'll just be like--
it's like I come up,
and everybody cheers.
It's so crazy.
It's the most.
It's so extra.
I love it.
That's definitely the funnest.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
What would you say is
the most challenging part
of being in the show?
Is it going on last minute?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I think--
there's been a
whole arc of things
that I've considered challenging
and overcome, more or less.
You know, at first,
I think it had
to do with the stress of being
associated with the brand.
It's, like I said,
it's just magnificent.
It's just this very big thing.
So I think that that was
difficult for me a little bit.
And then I was very
homesick for a long time.
SPEAKER: Well, you're home now.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
Yeah, I know.
So that's it.
And it's interesting just
really not having a home now.
I mean, yeah, this is my home.
But you know what I mean.
We're touring.
So that's been tough.
But then as far as the
performance goes, like I said,
it used to be having
such a short notice,
such a short amount of
time to prepare and go on.
But I don't know.
It's interesting, because things
that I considered challenging
are now things that
I kind of enjoy.
It's all kind of transformed
into something else.
I guess now it's just
making the most out of it
and trying to remember that--
because sometimes it
does feel like a job.
You know, we've been doing
this for a year, over a year.
And it does feel like going
to the office sometimes.
It does feel a little
bit crazy sometimes.
So I guess remembering that--
you know, I feel like
every period of my life
I look back on the
previous period, I'm like,
oh, that was the best.
But while I was going through
it, it didn't feel that way.
So now I'm just trying
really hard to be like, yeah,
this really is awesome.
So I guess just trying to take
that in while it's happening.
SPEAKER: So can you tell
us a little bit more
about how you got
involved with Hamilton,
and what the audition
process was like?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
I was really, really fortunate.
So I graduated college in May
2016, and I was able to get--
at most theater college,
performance colleges,
we have this thing called a
showcase, which we basically
go to New York City and then
prepare a song and a scene
or something with our class for
a bunch of agents and managers
and casting directors and
stuff like that-- just
a bunch of people, anybody
who wants to attend.
And I was fortunate enough
to get signed out of that.
And my agent was very,
very, very good to me.
She's really awesome.
I love her.
And she was able to
get me an appointment.
You know, I did auditions.
I moved there over the
summer, to New York City.
I did a show around Ithaca, and
then I moved to New York City
after that.
And I was just
auditioning around.
It was mostly workshops,
just smaller projects,
like start-up things.
I was in callbacks for
"Aladdin" for a while,
but I'm just bad at tap dance.
So it didn't end up panning.
And then around-- I
think it was October
was when I got an
appointment for this.
And then I went in, and it was--
they have a general mail packet.
It had "Dear Theodosia,"
"Blow Us All Away,"
"Washington On Your
Side," I think.
Yeah.
And then I did that.
And they called me back
in for "Sons of Liberty"
and "Hamilton."
And then it was
like, oh, good job.
OK, can you learn
these 50 songs?
And then I had to
learn so much music.
It was crazy.
So I ended up--
I think it was actually like
eight songs or eight cuts.
And then I learned them all,
and then I went back in,
and they asked me to
do like two of them.
And then it was a crazy process.
I think I had--
I want to say I had
seven callbacks.
And it took two months.
And it was one of
those things where
it was like, I would do one.
I didn't know how I did.
And then it would be a week
of just thinking about it.
And then they would email
me and be like, hey,
can you come in
tomorrow morning?
I'd say, yeah, sure.
You've always got to say yes.
You know, I was
just starting out.
I got no leverage.
What am I going to say?
No, I have a 2 o'clock.
So then I did that
like six, seven times.
And then the last
one was a dance call,
because they hadn't
seen me dance yet.
So I was like, great.
And then I showed up, and
there was nobody there.
I said, what's going on?
I'm in the wrong place.
Oh, my gosh, I was freaking out.
Because obviously I just--
I don't know, I was just
stressed all the time.
So then there was nobody
there, and I was asking around.
And I asked the
person at the desk--
I can't remember their name.
But she was like, no,
this is the right place.
Yeah.
They'll see you shortly.
And it was just the associate
choreographer who came out,
and he was like, come on in.
And then it was just me and him.
And I was like, why me?
Why?
This is the worst.
And then, it was so
funny, because you know,
it's not like I can't dance.
You know, I'm fun at parties.
I can bob.
I do OK.
You know, that's not like me.
SPEAKER: It's
tough choreography.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
Exactly.
It's craziness.
And so there's a mover
call and a dancer call,
and they put me
in the dance call.
And then he was teaching
me all these crazy moves.
And I said, no, this is it.
This is the end.
But I think they just wanted to
see how I moved or something,
or how fast I picked it up.
I don't really
know but whatever.
It worked out.
SPEAKER: It sure did.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
And that was the last one,
and I didn't hear anything
for two weeks.
And then I got the call
right before Christmas.
It was December 23.
And my family lives
in Puerto Rico.
I mean, they're
all Puerto Rican.
So I was on my way to
visit them for Christmas,
and I was literally on
my way to the airport,
and my agent called me.
And then she told
me that I got it.
And I stopped the Uber.
I was like, I had to get out.
So I just literally--
I'm sure I looked
like a crazy person.
But I literally just got
out of the car and just ran.
I just ran around.
And then I just
called three people.
I ran some more, and
I called three more,
and then rinse and repeat.
And then I went to Puerto Rico,
and I felt like a superhero.
I felt so cool.
SPEAKER: Life changing moment.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I know.
It really-- yeah.
And then we started rehearsals
like two weeks later.
It was great.
SPEAKER: So before I saw
"Hamilton" for the first time
in 2015, I have to admit
my American history
knowledge was lacking a bit.
How much American
history did you
know before starting the show?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I
mean, I don't know--
a fair amount.
No.
I'm--
SPEAKER: I knew Alexander
Hamilton is on the $10 bill,
and Burr shot him in a duel.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Can I tell
you something embarrassing?
SPEAKER: Sorry to my
high school teachers,
but that's all I remember.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
I literally--
because I think I was just so
focused on learning the words.
I remember there
was a moment where
I was like, oh, the $10 founding
father, like, two months
into rehearsal.
Yeah.
I mean, so I guess not a lot.
But that's why I love this
show so much, especially
with the outreach that we
do with schools, and just
the amount that we talk with
students and stuff like that.
It really made me
passionate about learning
about our history
as a country, and I
think it really has that effect
on, I feel like, everybody.
I didn't know a
lot of this stuff.
And some of it's obviously--
it's dramatized and
stuff like that.
Some things get glossed over.
I mean, you have to.
We have three hours
to tell a lifetime.
But it made me
passionate about--
it made me want to
learn more about it.
So definitely the process
has made me smarter.
I think beforehand, no, I
didn't know a lot about it.
I knew that Hamilton was a
dude who existed at one point,
and there was a show
about him with rad music.
SPEAKER: So segueing into
education, which you just
mentioned.
So since the show's
inception, there
has been a huge initiative for
education-- making the show
accessible to students.
For those who aren't
familiar, can you
tell us a bit more about
the EduHam program,
and what those
performances are like?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so fabulous.
I'm obsessed with that.
I mean, you see just the
most passionate kids.
It's very inspiring
to me as a performer.
You know, it's just like--
I don't know.
They'll come in, and
they'll do anything,
like a poem, a rap, just
spoken word, whatever,
make a speech, just something
about something that they
believe in.
And everybody brings
in different ideas
with similar drives behind
it that are just like--
I don't know.
I guess for me,
I feel like I was
a relatively soft spoken
person about my own opinions
up until--
I don't know.
Even now, I don't--
I'm not really loud-mouthed
about the things
that I believed.
And I wish I was
a little bit more.
But it's so cool to see
how this show just inspires
kids who are just younger
than 18, kids who are still
maturing, to really just speak
up about what they believe in.
It's so cool.
That's just something that I--
I don't want to say I
was taught not to do it.
I just didn't believe in myself
and my opinions and the things
that I felt and the things
that I believe to the extent
that this show is getting
people to do that.
You know what I mean?
I feel like I'm not
articulating this well.
But it's just so cool to
see that from kids so young.
Oh, my gosh, it's amazing.
SPEAKER: A new generation
of theater-goers.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Exactly.
And just a new--
it really is like watching
it and being like,
this is the future.
It's so-- it makes me just
feel so good about, I guess,
what's to come in the arts,
and what's to come politically.
SPEAKER: So off of that--
so you said these kids
are inspiring to you.
Is there anyone who
inspired you to do theater?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: A
bunch of people, yeah.
It was a culmination
of a lot of things.
I mean, to be
honest, my trajectory
is a little bit all over the
place as far as the things
that I wanted to do growing up.
I played football for a
long time-- not a long time.
I mean, I played football
for like three years
going into high school.
My story is so corny.
I played football, and then the
musical was going to happen,
and I was like, I can't do both.
And then I quit football,
and then I did the musical.
I was Marius in Fairview
High School's production
of "Les Miserables."
And I remember my
sophomore year I
did this thing called
Pop Show, which is just
like a culmination
of acts and songs
that the students would put on.
And that was my
first time performing
in front of an audience.
I did "Your Song" by Elton John
with a couple of my friends.
And I always liked to
sing, but I had not
performed like that before.
The first time I did
that was when I was 16,
and that's when I found out
that I really, really loved it.
I had the best time.
And it was not something
that I considered
to be a viable career path.
I mean, when you're
coming up, especially
if you want to be a
performer, everybody
tells you not to do it--
everybody.
I remember doing master
classes with people
who were theatergoers, and the
thing that they would always
say, it was--
it pissed me off.
It was, if you can do anything
else, you should do it.
SPEAKER: Good thing
you didn't listen.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I know.
I didn't.
Yeah.
And I don't feel like I
could do anything else.
I mean, I don't know if I'd
be happy doing anything else.
So originally I wanted to
sing, and I didn't really
exactly know how to
approach that avenue.
And I think musical
theater was a medium that--
I don't know.
It was just such a unique
way of storytelling
that I hadn't experienced
before the age of 17.
Like I said, it was my
junior year of high school.
And then I did the musical
again when I was a senior,
and that's kind of what did
it, where I was like, wow,
this is just a really
beautiful avenue
with which to tell a story.
And it's such a--
yeah.
So then after that I auditioned
for a bunch of colleges,
and I actually wanted to go
to Berklee for production
and design at first.
And then they were so expensive.
And so I didn't
end up going there.
And then I went
to Ithaca College,
which I love their program.
I didn't consider
myself an actor.
Like I said, I was
mostly a singer.
And Ithaca was
very acting-heavy.
And at first I really
didn't like that.
But then I got really,
really into it.
Now I just really
like to act, too.
I ended up doing a
lot of straight plays
while I was there.
I honestly can't remember
what you originally asked.
SPEAKER: It was who
inspired you to do theater.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I just
told you my whole story.
SPEAKER: You're good.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
A bunch of people.
I had a bunch of teachers who--
yeah.
A teacher at Fairview, her
name is Janice Vlachos.
You know, she's been a big part.
I almost didn't do--
it was choir that
originally led me in.
And I didn't sign up for
choir my sophomore year.
I was like, choir's lame.
You know, I was in football.
And I wanted to be
one of those guys.
And that's offensive
to those guys.
They were nice people.
And I remember I didn't
sign up my sophomore year.
And then I got my schedule,
and choir was on my schedule.
And I said, WTF?
And I went up to
Janice, and I said, why?
And she said, yeah,
you're doing choir.
And I said, I didn't sign up.
She said, you're going to do it.
You're going to do it.
And then I did, and it was fun.
I had a great time.
And that's how I
ended up doing that.
So honestly, her.
And then I had a bunch of
really supportive friends,
and their families were
really supportive of me.
And my family was
And yeah, I think it was just
a lot of people really believed
in me when I didn't
believe in myself.
And that's a big part of it.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
So you mentioned a lot of people
told you not to do theater.
Opposite of that, what was
the best piece of advice
you've ever received?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I can't
think of a specific piece
of advice that I've been given.
I think-- you know,
this sounds so specific,
but I think I
realized really young
that I can get away with a
lot of stuff if I just smile.
SPEAKER: Talk less, smile more.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Exactly,
like literally that.
Because I remember growing
up, I used to get into trouble
and be like, oh, sorry.
And then they'd
be like, oh, you.
You know, it would
turn into one of those.
So it kind of became a habit.
And then I think
eventually it prohibited me
from being genuinely
vulnerable, just
because I had fallen into the
habit of just smiling whenever
I was feeling anything.
This is what I'm saying.
It's very specific.
But someone-- I had
an acting teacher just
say, you're smiling so much.
You're smiling at everything.
Why are you smiling so much?
You're sad right now.
This scene is sad.
Express that.
This text is not telling you
to be a smiley little kid.
And then I thought about that.
And at first I was just
like, OK, I just won't smile.
But that sounds like
really jaded advice.
But I'm telling you, it's
one of those things where
I thought about
it, and I realized
how little of my
actual feelings I
was allowing to
show other people
and to express to
myself, because instead I
had deflected it.
It was just like, oh, eh.
And then it carried
over into my acting,
where that was a real
acting fallback that I had,
where I would just
smile at everything.
And then I kind of
stopped doing that,
and I just found a whole
spectrum of emotions
that I guess I had
not considered before.
Like I said, it's a
very specific thing.
But the best advice I ever
got was somebody telling me
not to smile.
You know.
The world's a crazy place.
SPEAKER: So switching
gears a bit,
the musical's about
founding fathers.
And while many of them made huge
contributions to our country,
they were also humans
who were deeply flawed--
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Of course.
SPEAKER: --and made mistakes.
How does this affect
your portrayal
of these historical figures?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Honestly,
I think there's a duality
to every human being, and it's
really important to take that
into consideration.
And you know, I'm glad that--
I mean, they really addressed
that mostly with Hamilton.
You know, obviously
he cheated on his wife
and sort of dropped the ball
with his son dying in a duel.
But that doesn't really discount
any of the contributions
that he made to society and our
economy and the building blocks
that he set.
As far as my portrayal of
the people, I don't know,
I think that's really important.
It shouldn't be hid.
Truth is truth, and it matters.
It's reality, and that's
really, really important.
The USA has a shady history.
It's so shady.
But we're here now,
and hopefully we're
educated about it.
I mean, I think that's
really important that we
see all sides of the story,
because I think it really helps
us going forward in proceeding.
Thomas Jefferson wasn't
historically a nice dude,
I guess.
I mean, I don't know a
crazy a lot about him.
I was more focused on just
learning the blocking.
But I know that he was a
big proponent of slavery.
But he made a lot of
contributions, too.
Everybody is flawed in every
story that you ever tell.
Hopefully-- in order to
be a dynamic character,
you have to have flaws.
In order to be a human
being you have to.
It shouldn't be ignored.
It should be--
I don't know about
embraced sometimes,
but yeah, that's important.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
OK.
So you've been in this cast
for a little bit over a year,
and you've traveled cities
all over the country
with the "Hamilton" cast.
What is it like having
different audiences,
performing in front
of different cities?
Do you get different reactions?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
Yeah, for sure.
It's so interesting.
I feel like in every city people
laugh in different places.
That's primarily the
one that I notice
is sometimes people will laugh.
It's funny.
In the EduHams,
there was one where--
I think it was last week or
something-- where there's
this song "Say No to This."
It's like, "led me to her bed,
let her legs spread instead."
And then like,
everybody was like, oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Like that.
They freaked out about it.
I thought it was so funny.
And then there was one-- at the
end, spoiler alert, but also,
it's history--
Hamilton gets shot.
SPEAKER: Sorry.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
Like Wikipedia,
they literally say it
in the first number.
SPEAKER: It's in the first song.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
I'm not sorry.
But yeah, he got shot.
And then as soon-- it was
like [IMITATING GUNSHOT]..
And then as soon as that
happened, there was silence.
And somebody said, oh, no!
It's was so funny.
And then everybody
laughed in the audience.
It's so weird to be a
performer in moments like that,
because it's just like, how
do I not acknowledge this?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, my gosh.
So yeah, it varies.
SPEAKER: And going
off of that, have
you had any on-stage
or backstage mishaps?
And if so, how did
you handle that?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Hell, yeah.
Heck, yeah.
I mean, that happens.
Especially, you
know, I'm a cover,
so I don't do these
tracks every day.
So my debut-- my first time
ever going on, I did it.
It was for Mulligan-Madison.
And the whole thing
went, you know, as good
as could be expected
for the first time.
I didn't make any
crazy mess-ups.
And I was like, you
know, this is good.
I'm living breezy.
We're golden.
The last line that I have in
the entire show, I just forgot.
It was so embarrassing.
And Josh Henry-- he's our
original Burr-- he just
said, "President Madison."
And I said, he took our
country from bankruptcy--
[INHALES]
SPEAKER: To prosperity?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Because
it's, he took our country from
bankruptcy to prosperity.
I hate to admit it, but he
doesn't get enough credit
for all the credit he gave us.
I said, he took our
country from bankruptcy
to financial stability--
and then I was like,
I hate to admit it,
but he doesn't get enough
credit for all the credit.
And then he's like,
who lives, who dies,
who-- so they cut me off.
It was so embarrassing.
They just had to pretend
it didn't happen.
And there's been times where
I've been in the wrong--
but that's the funniest one.
I mean, there's a bunch
of really funny ones.
I mean, I don't want to
blow up anybody's spot.
But there was one time when
our George Washington just--
you know, you do it,
you get into the groove,
and I think you expect
it to just come to you,
and sometimes it just doesn't.
And there was one time when--
ladies and gentlemen,
the issue on the table.
Secretary Jefferson-- you
know, the cabinet battle.
So he comes out and he
says, ladies and gentlemen--
woo!
[LAUGHTER]
He's just the best.
He's the most-- he's
just such a jubilant man.
So he goes, [LAUGHS].
I lost my train of thought.
Secretary Jefferson,
you have the floor.
It was so funny.
And then they just started.
Yeah.
It totally happens.
SPEAKER: There's a lot of
lines and songs to remember.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
There's a lot of lines.
And it's great, because it's
so dense that usually you just
forget about it in like
10 measures anyways.
But it happens all the time.
SPEAKER: Thank you
for sharing that.
Kind of overall big
question-- what does this show
mean to you?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: It
means so many things.
And it's progressed.
I think so much
life has happened
while I've been on tour.
Like, our George Washington
had his second child
while we were in LA.
Josh Henry-- well, no.
I guess that was after--
yeah.
That was after-- his
baby was just born.
I don't know what I'm saying.
But you know, a
lot of friendships
have been developed.
Things have happened.
Journeys have been gone through.
I have made a progression
as a human being
through this process,
just because it
comes with so many experiences.
It meant a different thing to
me before than it does now.
You know?
I think before it meant what--
I mean, and it still does.
I think it's this idea
and it's this movement
that's very inclusive.
And it involves
everyone, and it's
a choice to stand up
for what you believe in.
And I think that has remained
consistent to me throughout.
And I think over time it
became a lot about growth,
and a lot about
internal progression
and overcoming my fears
and overcoming my--
inner demons is the wrong word.
I mean, I had a lot of like--
Thomas Jefferson,
that track, homie
Daveed won a Tony for that.
Who am I?
You know what I mean?
It was one of those things
where I think figuring out
what it is that I had to
offer as a human being
and as a performer has
progressed a lot over time
through this show.
And it's funny,
because the show itself
is a lot about
embracing yourself
and what you believe in.
And like I said, that
remains consistent.
And that has been
a huge arc for me
throughout this entire process.
I mean, I don't have that
much experience in general
with life.
I'm 23.
I was blessed enough to get this
pretty shortly out of college.
So a lot of my post-graduate
life has been this show.
Yeah.
I couldn't be happier about it.
SPEAKER: So you
mentioned Daveed.
Were you able to meet up with
any of the original cast?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER: Have you
met all of them?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Daveed used
to come hang out with us all
the time.
Yeah, we had a barbecue
with him when we were in LA.
He's dope.
He's a good guy.
SPEAKER: Did they give any
advice about the roles?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Oh, I
mean, I've never really asked.
I've tried not to be--
I imagine that--
I don't know.
I imagine that if I had
done it for a while,
and then I was finished
with it, I'd probably
just want to live my life.
SPEAKER: So you guys don't
talk about "Hamilton."
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I try
not to talk about "Hamilton"
with those people.
But we met a lot of them.
Oke came to-- Oke and Daveed
were both at the opening night.
Lin was, too.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
We got to meet with him.
They're all great.
I don't know.
Yeah, they're just people.
It's so funny.
I feel like coming
out of college,
these were people that I--
I mean, the whole thing
is relatively new,
but in my senior year, we
talked about them in class
and talked about
this whole thing.
And talked about Tommy
Kail, Andy Blankenbuehler,
Alex Lacamoire-- the
original creative team.
And it's so crazy to
just hang out with them.
You know, it's funny to
have your role models just
become people before
your eyes and have
a regular conversation
about something that has
nothing to do with your job.
Yeah.
That's been really interesting.
Talking with Lin, and just
having a regular conversation
about his flight into LA--
it was wild.
I'm just like, wow,
this is just so--
yeah.
So yes, I've met a lot of them.
SPEAKER: Very cool.
So we're going to open
up to audience questions.
I know we have some
mics around the room.
If anyone has a question, did
you want to raise your hand,
and we can bring a mic to you?
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about the journey
between getting
the part, like the
rehearsals, to opening night?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Totally.
Yeah.
So got it, freaked
out, went to Puerto
Rico, felt like a superhero--
SPEAKER: Ran around.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
Ran around.
Just ran around the
whole span of Manhattan.
And then it was awesome.
And we started rehearsal,
and it was in Midtown.
It was from 10:00
to 6:00 every day.
I mean we had to learn a whole
show in like three weeks,
so it was pretty intense.
It was crazy at the
time, and now I'm
really thankful
that this happened.
But the covers are not
priority when teaching a show
to an original company.
We were all learning the
show at the same time.
So the priority was obviously
teaching the principles
and the onstage cast their
parts as fast as possible.
And so a lot of me
learning my stuff--
I had to do it through
osmosis and on my own.
And I had to really pay
attention to what was going on
and absorb as much
as I possibly could
so that I could go
home and review it.
And that was really crazy.
I'd never had to do
anything like that before.
It was like nobody
was holding my hand.
I felt like it was so difficult.
But at the same
time, I don't know.
I feel like that built so
much character, just having
to do something like that.
Nobody was telling
me what to do,
and I was still
expected to do it.
And nobody talked to
me about that, either.
That was the weird thing
is I really wasn't sure
what the expectation
was, and when
I was supposed to know my stuff
by, and what that was like.
So I just tried to learn
it as fast as I could.
And fortunately, I
had that attitude,
because I had to go on
really, really early.
My debut in Madison happened
I think the second week
of previews, which usually--
I don't know.
It's not like it's unheard of,
but it usually doesn't happen.
It was crazy.
But fortunately I had
been so stressed about it
that I had already learned it.
It was all I thought about.
Literally I would go to bed
and be like, what if like,
what if, I don't know,
somebody just quit.
I don't know.
I was just thinking,
all kinds of scenarios
flying by in my head.
And I would have
dreams about waking up
for opening night and
people being like, hey,
you have to go on for this
track you've never done.
And it starts in 30.
Good luck!
It was a lot of that.
And then when they knew that
I was going to have to go on,
they were really hands-on with
me, which was super helpful.
And I got to rehearse
one-on-one with everybody.
And then I had a
put-in, which was great.
And then I think it was
the week after that I
had to debut a different role.
It was like, the first
two were just nuts, dude.
Because that one--
the next week when
I had to debut that
other one, I got one day.
They told me the day before.
Like, the night
before was my day off.
I was out with friends.
We were doing this
community outreach thing
with a homelessness
outreach in San Francisco.
And then it was just
afterwards, we were hanging out.
I was just having a glass of
wine, and then I get a call.
And it was like,
hey, Ruben is out.
You have to go on tomorrow.
And I just put my
glass of wine down.
And I was like, I
have to go home.
And then I just went
over it a bunch.
That was pretty intense.
That was one of
those things where
I feel like now it's a year
out, so I can talk about it
a little bit more candidly.
But I remember I had
a put-in, an emergency
put-in the next morning,
which was great.
But I remember there
being certain numbers
where I was like,
I just have to--
I just I have to
not hit anybody.
I would be like
maneuvering around.
I didn't know where
I was supposed to be,
but I knew approximately
that I should be there,
because people were here.
It was nuts.
It was the most
terrifying thing ever.
But then it was one of those
things where after that, I
was like, I can do anything.
Oh, my god.
That was crazy.
And that was--
I think that's the
most stress that I've
had with this experience.
And after that it
was smooth sailing.
I think nothing will
be harder than that.
After that, it became a
little bit more routine.
We rehearse once, twice a week,
and we'll run through the show,
and I'll be a different
person every time.
And it became a little
more routine after that.
But yeah, the start was
actually super turbulent for me.
Ooh, it was crazy.
AUDIENCE: If you
could play any role
in any non-Hamilton
musical, what would it be?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
I really want to be--
this isn't a
musical, but I really
want to be in "Streetcar
Named Desire."
I'd love to be Stanley.
That would be awesome.
Have you guys seen that?
With Marlon Brando--
have you seen that movie?
Oh, it's so awesome.
That dude-- I don't know.
I mean, everybody talks
about Marlon Brando like he's
the best actor
ever, because he is.
Or at least a young
Marlon Brando,
before he had an
earpiece with the lines.
But back when he tried,
he was really good.
I think that's my dream.
I would love to be in that show.
I have to think about a musical.
There's a bunch of
musicals I'd love to be in.
I would love to be Warner
in "Legally Blonde."
That would be so much fun.
This is my aesthetic, guys.
I love being--
I'm trying to think
of a word that's--
I just love to be
kind of a jerk.
It's like my favorite thing.
And you know, I go in for like
casting all the time for like--
I've got a young face, so I
go in for high school bullies
and jocks and stuff a lot.
Yeah, they're a little
two-dimensional,
but they're so much fun.
It's so much fun to just be that
dude who's like, heh, you think
you're so cool with your pants.
I don't know.
I would love to be Warner
in "Legally Blonde."
That would be so much fun.
I don't know if I'd
call that my dream,
but it'd definitely
be a good time.
AUDIENCE: So my daughter
goes to Fairview.
Have you been to Fairview,
been back to school
since you've been--
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
I went and talked to one
of the choirs last week.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the response
been from the students?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
Oh, I love them.
They were just a lot of fun.
It wasn't like-- I mean, it
wasn't anything like this.
It was very casual,
and I just told them
about how I used to go there
and my process from then.
They were really nice.
They were very enthusiastic,
and I loved talking to them.
It was very strange going back.
And being in Denver in
general has been very crazy.
There's a lot of
nostalgia and sentiment,
and what it means to be
home, addressing that.
And especially going
back to Fairview,
it was like, being
in that choir room,
and literally
looking at the seats
that I used to sit in in
the tenor two section.
I don't know.
It was so wild.
And I think they got that.
And hopefully-- and
everybody always told me
when I was in high
school, it was like,
you're going to miss this.
This is going to be the
stuff that you miss.
Obviously, like I sucked,
so I was like, whatever.
I hate high school.
But a lot of my formative
experiences happened.
And I was trying
to tell them that.
Hopefully it didn't [WHOOSH]
like it did with me.
But it was really, really,
really, really cool
talking to them.
It meant a lot to me.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
How many people in roles
like yours are there?
Do all the main
characters have someone?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I think
everybody has at least two
covers.
Laurens has three covers.
And there's another guy who
covers the parts that I cover,
but he does like two
dance tracks, also.
Everybody has at least two.
AUDIENCE: So every performance
there's two people there
who could step in?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
Who could potentially step
in if something happened.
AUDIENCE: So then what does
the costume room look like?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Large.
AUDIENCE: Because
you have to have
the costumes for all
the different roles
that you could potentially play.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Yeah.
My gondola is stacked.
It's just got all of--
I want to say there's like
34 cast members in total
and about half are
off-stage covers.
So yes, there's a lot.
It's so much.
AUDIENCE: How many costume
changes do you usually have?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Usually like
three, I think, in the show.
The first act-- let me think.
OK.
We have the parchment
in the beginning,
and then we have the
regular study coats,
revolutionary outfits.
And then Lafayette changes
into a general outfit.
And then he changes into
his Jefferson costume.
And then Jefferson
doesn't change, and then
back into parchment.
So I guess six.
That's the whole show.
But in the first act it's like
three per character-- about.
I don't know.
Yeah.
That's a good amount.
There's one quick change
at the end that's crazy,
but that's the only one
that's really that stressful.
Because usually we have
a minute to change.
But there's one--
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
Duh.
But at the end,
there's one where
I remember the first
couple of times I did it
I missed the next number.
Because it's literally like,
you have to go off and woosh!
You just take off all your--
I think it's like 45 seconds
to change your entire outfit.
And that one's crazy.
But all the other ones are fine.
No stress.
AUDIENCE: So I imagine when you
go to-- different theaters can
have slightly different stages.
Does anything have to change?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Generally
we'll show up to each theater
like three hours early and
just talk through the changes.
Usually we won't
have to run through--
well, we run through
a couple of things
just to get lighting and stuff.
Because usually,
that's the thing
is it's a very
lighting-heavy show.
And I think theaters are
equipped differently in the way
that they use lights
and stuff like that.
So that's usually what
we have to go through
is changing the
lighting and everything.
But generally the stages
are roughly the same sizes
proportionally.
Sometimes props will
be in different places,
so we have to live through that.
But it's really, really similar.
They do a really
good job at making
everything kind of what it is.
And we have a turntable that
we take with us everywhere,
so that's nice.
At least that's the same.
That's the thing that
needs to be the same.
I don't know if you guys have
seen that, but it's crazy.
SPEAKER: It's a great
use of a turntable.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Oh, yeah.
And aesthetically,
it's beautiful.
But learning how to walk on
that thing was a process.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: And dance on it.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
And dance on it.
And I don't even have to
like dance dance on it.
People are just doing spins
and crazy stuff on that thing.
Whoa, it's wild.
AUDIENCE: I imagine that
you perform a lot regularly.
So does it become routine,
or are there a lot
of highs and lows each week?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Sometimes.
I feel like the first show
is always kind of weird.
It's hard to just
get right into it,
especially when I'll have
usually two weeks in between.
I don't know.
They've been getting
mileage out of me lately,
but yeah, there'll usually
be like a week or two
in between when I'll
have to go on again.
And it's always just a little
bit weird, the first one.
That opening number
is so stressful to me.
I cannot lie.
Because it's so exposed, and
I still get a little nervous.
That doesn't go
away, unless I do it
multiple times in a row,
usually the second one I
won't be nervous.
But the first number
I'm always nervous,
because that first line,
especially as Laurens, where
it's like Burr comes
out, he says his thing,
and Laurens is the second
person to come out.
And it's just you and
the audience, baby.
And literally, the spotlight
is just like [WHOOSH]..
That was the thing
when I first came on.
Because I have to
figure out where
to breathe, because the
line is kind of long.
And I remember the
first time I ever
did it, going out and then
looking and just being like--
my pupils just, and I was like,
the $10 dollar, founding father
without--
like I was so-- it's kind of
nerve wracking the first time.
And I haven't-- it still is.
It doesn't really
become routine.
But it's definitely way
easier than it used to be.
I imagine it becomes
routine for other people,
but for me, I'm always
really excited to go on.
I always have a great
time, and I'm always
very thankful when
I get to do it.
So far I haven't been able to
do it enough times where I--
or I don't know that it would--
I haven't been able to
do it so much where I
feel like it's like, whatever.
I talk in gestures.
You guys just have
to get used to it.
It's just who I am.
Just accept me for me.
I think for some people
it definitely is.
It's just what they do.
I think mostly just
because of my job,
if I only had to
cover one person it
would be a little different.
It would totally be
routine if I did.
But the thing is that
I always have to like--
my brain has three
modes for each track.
So I always have to
pay attention to that,
or I'm going to say
somebody else's line.
It's just going to happen.
AUDIENCE: If your
friends at Google
could create one technology
to help the theater community,
what would it be?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Oh, my gosh.
AUDIENCE: Dream big.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: Ooh!
I feel like what I say matters.
Damn.
AUDIENCE: It can be anything.
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I
guess, I wish there was--
that's a really big thing.
For auditions, I
think the process
of finding music
and scenes and stuff
that really fits the project,
that's really difficult
and strenuous for me, I guess.
I think it is for
a lot of actors--
just finding music that's
easily accessible and works
and is in the style of the
show that you're going in for.
That's a tough research
process that has
to happen for a lot of people.
So something where I
can be like, hey Google,
I need a song that
makes me look spunky
and I can hit an A in it.
I guess if you could do
that, that'd be great.
SPEAKER: We'll tell
our engineers if anyone
wants to take on that project.
AUDIENCE: Are you able to
leave all the characters
on stage or so?
Or whenever you're
out in everyday life
are you like, I'm being
super Jefferson right now?
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA: I love that.
I'm so Jefferson right now.
No.
I leave them on stage.
I mean, they're all like
me, different sides of me.
The way that I do it.
I mean, that's what
acting is to me,
it's just bringing myself to
the circumstance and whatever.
I meet the disposition halfway.
So that's the thing is,
I am extra by nature.
But I don't really consider
that bringing the characters
with me.
I think that's just
because I bring--
that's already me.
I bring it to that.
So no, I'm not like
method or anything.
I'm not like--
I don't know.
I don't know if
that answered that.
I don't know.
No, I don't really have a
problem leaving it on stage.
I've had to go through a process
of really separating this
from my personal identity,
just because, if I didn't, I
would go nuts.
So yeah, I think I'm good
at leaving work at work.
And when I'm in
my personal life,
maybe I'm being Jefferson,
but I don't call it that.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: So I saw the show
a few weeks ago in Denver.
It was awesome.
And you had mentioned
sometimes you forget a line,
or somebody forgets a line.
When I saw the show, it felt
like nobody forgot anything,
and it was perfect.
Has the cast as a
whole ever felt like,
at the end of a
performance, wow,
that was the best
performance we've ever done?
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
I don't know.
I think different
adjectives are used.
I don't know if anybody has ever
said that about a performance
that they've just done.
There's definitely been
days where I've been like,
I am nailing it!
But I don't know.
There are definitely some
days when it's like, man,
this is really fun.
Because obviously
you do it every day,
and not every show is
going to be the same.
But there are definitely
certain shows.
And it is, if the audience is
reacting, it feels really good.
And there are definitely
shows where at the end,
we're like, that
was really great.
That was awesome.
And it feels really good.
Yeah, for sure, I guess.
I don't know if we'll ever
say, like, that was the one.
It doesn't get better
than this, baby.
Yeah.
All downhill from here.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm sure that yours was probably
a day where it was like, wow,
that felt really good.
SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for being here.
This was such a treat for us.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH ANDRÉS RIVERA:
It was so my pleasure.